[Music]
we want to tell you about a
groundbreaking bit of research that
proves a south dakota man is the closest
living descendant of the legendary
native american leader sitting bowl 73
year old ernie lapoint is the great
grandson
of the lakota sioux chief who died all
the way back in 1890.
sitting bull is best known of course for
his victory his victory in the battle of
little bighorn against lieutenant
colonel george custer the family
connection was confirmed using a new
method that analyzes dna fragments and
it took scientists 14 years to figure
out how to pull that dna from a 130 year
old strand of sitting bull's hair that
was for some reason stored at the
smithsonian institution in washington
the point said many people tried to
question his relationship to sitting
bull in the past and he wasn't at first
sure the dna analysis would actually
work so glad it did and you know i i
gave up on him because
he took the air in 2007 you know and
that's another way of proving
that i'm related to my great grandfather
so i have the oral stories
the ceremonial the paper now the dna is
the scientific thing of doing it
this is the first time dna has been used
to confirm a family relationship between
a living and a historical person in this
way scientists hope the technique could
help identify living descendants of
other notable people from the past i
wonder how far back they could go that's
awesome they just find no limit to it i
mean archaeologists have boxes and boxes
of stuff that they actually don't know
what to do with at places like the
smithsonian and they're just sort of
waiting for technology to come along
that
unlocks it
science is so important and it's a prime
example of why you should know your
history